Samsung is warning its customers about
conversations near the tech-savvy
television sets privacy policy policy
statement from Samsung that says quote
please be aware that if your spoken
words include personal or other
sensitive information that information
will be among the data captured and
transmitted to a third party through
their use of voice recognition that's
right your TV is listening to you if not
watching you how big a deal is this
consumer protection Council for the
Electronic Privacy Information Center
Julia Horowitz in Washington DC also
with us Bloomberg tuning in and SK
ventures partner Paul Kujawski
let me start with you Julian what am I
to make of this Smart TV watching me
listening to me
well it's pretty simple if you're
watching TV TV should not be watching
you back okay hey well I don't know it's
you know it's nice to everyone to chip
in a little bit know this is a serious
concern I think it's a it's a it's a
concern because Samsung should not be
collecting personal data from from
people who are watching television for
at least two reasons the first is that
it's unnecessary there could easily be
privacy enhancing technologies built-in
that would eliminate or minimize at
least the need to collect this personal
data from consumers and the second is
that consumers like the companies don't
know what's going to happen to the data
after its collected could röszke
what are you doing from your TV you
don't want people to see everything
possible I like to stand there and
recite my social security number as
often as possible is that wrong
apparently so no is this look-the the
Smart TV the TV that gathers information
big data artificial intelligence these
are we reached a point where we got to
start being concerned about our devices
watching us and that or the businesses
that might create no we should always be
concerned I just think that you know the
question here is you kind of have to
break it down is the objection that's
not just this step away from Samsung for
a second but is the objection that
connected devices use voice recognition
so let's start there is that the
objection I don't think that's the
objection because you know we're also
to be in favor of the idea that our
devices can listen to us and do things
based on the words we speak so then the
question is is what is the objection
that the words we speak are sometimes
relayed outside of the device well I
would hope that's not the objection
because that's the essence of cloud
services whatever you want to process
voice it often happens through a third
party in this case specifically it
sounds like it was nuan's where the the
information your voice data is being
transmitted to nuance which happens to
have you know great voice recognition
technology and that's no different than
what happens with Google or happens with
Apple with Siri you know the information
gets relayed there so is that the
objection I don't think that's the
objection here so then is the objection
you know the how good of a job they're
doing and on amaizing the data and you
know and that's a perfectly legitimate
concern I just think people privacy
advocates and others in general and
Samsung has done a poor job of this have
really kind of muddled the argument what
are we exactly objecting to here it's
really not clear to me because it's
certainly I don't think the objection
isn't that somehow devices in our homes
can act on voice commands because if
that's the objection people should go
back to living in caves there was there
was some time between voice command TVs
and caves but all right Julia it is the
ultimate issue here companies have to
think about the anonymization of this
data or door is there a point at which
they won't be able to collect it in
certain ways like like Siri or like on
TV well I think I would just like to to
correct something that Paul said which
is that the issue is not anonymization
it's certainly not the use of new
technologies I think that the real issue
is the use of I mean is over collection
and and not careful planning so
companies that don't know what use
they're going to put to data that they
collect should not be over collecting in
this way yeah I mean Paul I think it is
interesting okay well I think it's
interesting Paul companies have never
the lots of companies that never thought
they would be in an arena where they've
got to think about anonymizing data
right collection of cloud data of
random things that their customers are
doing saying whatever now have to think
about issues of privacy and all kinds of
companies have to worry about privacy
that never thought they would for sure
and you know when Apple had this issue a
year or so ago with respect to data
retention policies around Siri voice
data you know how long do they keep it
how is it tied to the users when does it
become fully disconnected from it even
in a randomized ID attached to users
these are all legitimate questions I
totally get that but my issue is with
respect to this notion it's a very broad
term and I really don't know what it
means but this notion of over collection
the whole notion of natural language
interfaces whenever you're dealing with
devices is is you know you listen
because you're not exactly sure where in
your users statement the actual command
resides people don't speak and these
kinds of barked out turn on watch
Bloomberg people don't talk like that
and they don't want to talk like that to
their devices and so as a result devices
have to listen through a whole you know
a set of expressions trying to figure
out which one of those are commands for
the television and if that constitutes
the boundary when that becomes
overharvesting when you actually
introduce natural language interfaces
we're kind of screwed because we're not
going to be able to introduce anything
that isn't sort of you know more complex
then you know turn on turn off watch
Bloomberg or whatever else which is sort
of a nonsensical position to take I
don't know I this is I think this is
gonna get interesting I mean I'm just
thinking about TVs and hotel rooms or
TVs when you walk down a this I don't
know it cuz there's an interesting story
affects a lot of companies and a lot of
important people people like Paul
kotovsky thank you very much as well as
Julia Horowitz of the epic Consumer
Protection Council thank you very much